merci monsieur le président sur le
premier ministre vous avez décrété avec
le président de la république l'état
d'urgence économique
force est de constater qu'en fait vous
êtes en train d'organiser l'état de
déliquescence économique dans votre plan
pour l'emploi est à la fois inefficace
et mensonger inefficace parce que qui
peut penser ici qu'une seule entreprise
va créer un emploi avec une prime à la
bosch de 2000 euros et on le sait aussi
mensonger parce que qui peut croire que
vous allez former cinq cent mille
chômeurs de plus alors face à cela en
plus vous mentez aux français parce que
le coup et ce mensonge il a un coût 2
milliards d'euros pour utiliser la
politique de l'emploi à des fins
uniquement électoralistes et pour
finalement sauvé le seul emploi qui
vaille celui du président de la
république alors vous ne pouvez pas et
vous ne pouvez plus camoufler aux
français la réalité du chômage par
l'illusion statistiques parce que le
camoufler c'est vous qui allez le subir
incapable effectivement de vous attaquer
aux réformes de fond pour sortir du
chômage de masse votre politique de
rustines a échoué avec 650 mille
chômeurs de plus en trois ans et demi le
verdict est implacable
ce que vous dit votre ministre de
l'économie c'est oser des nouvelles
solutions plutôt que de partir dans des
vieilles recettes vous qui était
monsieur le premier ministre à matignon
avec monsieur jospin au moment des
emplois jeunes
quand allez vous enfin abandonné
l'impasse des contrats aidés au profit
d'un vrai effort sur l'alternance
quand monsieur le premier ministre allez
vous enfin réformer le marché du travail
simplifier le code du travail et libérer
les énergies qu'il y a dans nos
entreprises
quand allez vous enfin cesser le
matraquage fiscal qui sera la marque de
fabrique de votre quinquennat et
réformer l'indemnisation chômage comme
la cour des comptes vous le demande
quand allez vous enfin agir au profit de
l'emploi et de la croissance
merci la parole est à madame myriam el
khomri ministre du travail de l'emploi
et de la formation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député damien abad il me
paraît important d'abord de répondre par
rapport à cette question du traitement
statistique du chômage
vous le savez bien les demandeurs
d'emploi qui sont formés ne
disparaîtront pas des statistiques de
pôle emploi
ils seront en catégorie d la catégorie
des la catégorie t vous en avez
l'information tous les mois par ailleurs
que vous pas est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils vont rester en catégorie d tout
le long de leur formation absolument pas
la réalité
la réalité c'est que nous partons des
besoins des entreprises et vous le savez
beaucoup d'entre vous ont fait campagne
justement sur l'absence de formation de
demandeurs d'emploi est ce que c'est ça
que vous critiquez que nous formions des
demandeurs d'emploi non vous criez le
fait que nous mettions nous doublons
justement l'effectif de formation et
nous le faisons pourquoi parce qu'il y
en a marre d'avoir ce débat dans notre
pays des emplois non pourvus parce qu'il
nous le savons avec une reprise de
l'activité économique
nous savons pertinemment que les
personnes les moins qualifiées resteront
sur le bord du chemin
donc admettez que l'investissement
humain on lui parlait de social de
traitement social que l'investissement
humain est bon pour la compétitivité de
notre économie c'est là où nous avons
une divergence de fond vous nous
comparez toujours à l'allemagne mais
faisons comme l'allemagne en termes de
formation des demandeurs d'emploi voilà
la question à laquelle nous est posée et
ça ça se fera pas avant que mas par
bassin d'emploi
sur l'apprentissage nous ouvrons les
titres s'étaient également essentielle
il vous plait l'entente bios life
permanent
enfin ma loi travail permettra pas ce
que nous croyons dialogue social nous
croyons justement la négociation au plus
près de l'entreprise pour permettre d
adaptation et c'est ça que nous allons
faire dans le cadre de la loi travail
nous en déplaise à une vraie différence
entre la droite et la gauche
merci madame la ministre la parole
l'état monsieur emeric bréhier merci
monsieur